- Thabo Bella Derrick Bradley Brant
Bickle and Marcus gross the Academy
presents a technical achievement award
for their work on the medusa capture
system gentlemen come get your
certificate
[Music]
[Music]
hmm we would like to thank our team back
home and to everybody who helped
realizing Medusa we would also like to
thank in specific specifically David
Terry taro for bringing Medusa into
production and our friends at ILM for
making good use of the system we'd also
like to thank the academy and everybody
in the industry who believed in us and
who supported us on a personal note I'd
like to thank my parents my family my
kids and in particular my amazing wife
who are here with us today
and who supported me unconditionally
thank you I just like to add a personal
thank you to all my close friends around
the world and to my family mom dad
Colleen and Neil here in the audience
and everyone else back home in Smiths
Falls Ontario Canada thank you for all
the love and the support even though
this took me so far away from home thank
you and a shout out to my family
especially my amazing girlfriend matina
we recently had a boy I love you so much
and thank you for all the support
so I want to thank first and foremost
all my friends at Disney at Jamie Andrew
Robb Nick Dave for all your ongoing
support of Disney research this is
fantastic and also to the Swiss Federal
Institute of Technology because this is
where we laid the crowns from medusa
finally to my family because they are so
patient with me thank you
[Applause]